Do you know that most men
don't actually expect you to cook three meals a day for them
Clean the whole house top to bottom
and cater to their every need
it's a little unrealistic to do all of these things
especially if you have to work a full time job and take care of the children
just like it's a little unrealistic to expect every man make over six figures
When men live alone
they eat prepped food or order take out
Do they really don't need to cook and clean for them all the time
IF and only if you like to THEN, it'll be appreciated
They’ll love you for it
but it's not necessary to keep a man
Men are such simple creatures
If you don't care to do the housekeeping
then don't
there's tons of men out there that do most of the house keeping
Men I know personally that do a majority of the household chores
that's just what works for their relationship
so it's not just a woman thing
Men will love you the same
but they appreciate you whenever you do these things
clean for them, cook for them
take care of them
I've openly expressed my opinions on cleaning and cooking for a man
y'all know where I stand on this
I just do it because I like to take care of my man
but I'm not saying you have to